[Music]
the i-team is learning more about the
moments leading up to a high-speed crash
which killed a one-year-old boy
his parents are accused of racing before
the crash in july
the i-team's vanessa murphy joins us now
with the story
yeah the child's father was not a
suspect at the scene of the crash but
once police obtained
video and reviewed cell phone records
the dad was arrested and charged
this afternoon lauren prescha and
cameron hubbard jones had a virtual
court appearance due to kovitt 19
precautions
they're charged with second-degree
murder child abuse and more
their one-year-old son royce was killed
in this crash on july 12 near rampart
and lake mead
presha was suspected of being drunk from
the start of the investigation
and once metro police obtained video
which shows
both parents racing and text messages
between the parents
hubbard jones also faced charges now
the i-team obtained new court records
and according to testimony from police
precious speed was around 120 miles per
hour
seconds before the crash she had cocaine
and
twice the legal limit of alcohol in her
system and
earlier in the day she texted hubbard
jones i want to get drunk
play tourist lol at fashion show
meaning fashion show mall the next text
is about
white claws that's seltzer with alcohol
in it they agree to meet after 1 pm
then in the evening the parents appear
to race moments before the crash
and royce is thrown from precious car
witnesses described the child's lifeless
body
at that scene presha and hubbard jones
are both
23 years old a jury trial is set for
october 26th
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now